there hasn't been a whole lot of uplift
to the year 2020 which is why cbs this
morning went looking for
some better news not in the headlines
but in something a little more eternal
there are a couple questions for you are
most people basically good
can we count on our fellow americans and
when it really matters
who among us would be there to help with
those questions in mind we adapted a
simple experiment from the world of
social science take a look
how are you as we flagged down shoppers
last week on new york's long island
we got one simple question it didn't
take long to discover
if you were to lose your wallet how
likely do you think it is
it'd get returned a lot of us have lost
faith
in our fellow man probably like
what like 10 percent what do you have
many people wouldn't expect to see that
wallet ever again
people finally can take it people would
find it and take it yeah
and if there was cash inside probably
the wallet gets returned and the
the cash is missing my id might be in
that about it
but all the credit cards the cash gone
and sure enough
a recent study found that most people
think this way believing the more money
in a lost wallet
the less likely it is to be returned but
what if we're wrong
about humanity with only one way to find
out we set up hidden cameras and filled
several plastic wallets with
65 dollars in cash to make it look
authentic we included a key
a grocery list and a stack of business
cards with the name and phone number
hi ma'am and then we lost him excuse me
sir
hi is this yours or more precisely a
producer passed off each wallet to a
perfect stranger
hi i found this just now right there in
the corner do you guys think maybe you
can
figure this out because i really have to
go there was absolutely nothing to stop
these people from wandering off
yeah he seems to be pondering it and in
fact
as we watch from a nearby car some folks
did walk away with our cash
but they were the exception of the eight
wallets we lost
five found their way back to us as
people either delivered the wallet to a
business or police station
we work for cbs we're doing a little uh
social psychology experiment
yeah or took the time oh you found my
wallet thank you
to see it safely returned in person well
thank you very much i appreciate it no
no definitely when you return the wallet
well what else would you do
well i don't know you tell me what else
would you do well i couldn't take it
that's for sure
why did you do it why it's dead you
shouldn't even have to answer that
question it's the right thing to do
it's the right thing to do how many
people do you think would do that
in this day and age i think a lot more
than people
think so yeah she's right our little
experiment was inspired by
and got results similar to those of a
landmark study published last year in
the journal science
more than 70 percent of lost wallets
were returned
if they had a large amount of money
inside and despite
our assumptions the more money the
wallet contained the more likely
it was to be returned i found it right
over here on the corner
in other words the more it mattered the
more people did
the right thing but stephen pinker could
have told you that
it feels good to really help someone
he's a cognitive psychologist and
professor at harvard
if there's an opportunity to confer a
large benefit to someone else
at a small cost to yourself
then you do it would it be too trite to
say that there's more good in the world
than we expect
i don't think it'd be too trite i like
the expression from abraham lincoln the
better angels of our nature
because it implies that we do have those
better angels but it also implies that
that's not
all there is to human nature well it
also suggests that the the angels are
not the underdog in fact they win quite
often
they win quite often and uh the
imperative for all of us
is to [ __ ] the rules the norms
uh the incentives uh so as to bring out
our better angels and to marginalize our
inner demons
he says the many negative things we
typically hear in the news
overshadow the many positive
developments all around us
man returns wallet after all isn't much
of a headline
and yet in his 2018 book enlightenment
now pinker makes the case for good news
finding that our lives by almost every
measure
are improving and the worst off parts of
the world today
are better off than the best off parts
not long ago
poverty has gone down literacy has gone
down violence has gone down
not by magic but when humans apply their
ingenuity to solving problems
every now and again they can succeed so
we got to admit it's getting
better not everywhere but mostly
isn't that interesting it is interesting
and it's really good news
yeah it is you were saying in that study
they lost they literally lost
six six hundred and fifty thousand
dollars yeah six hundred and fifty
thousand dollars all around the world
virtually every country in the world
and everywhere humanity does the right
thing most of the time
and in particular when there's more
money involved right we are there for
one another and we don't appreciate the
extent to which we are
so they got most of that 650 they did
yeah yeah i'm really happy to hear that
i
i do i always believe that there's more
good than not
but the 72 percent number did surprise
me and 72
will do that and uh stephen picker there
of harvard says it's also important to
recognize that even right
now humanity uh is working on our behalf
human ingenuity is coming to the rescue
in the form of the vaccines we've been
talking about uh
this morning and so while we still think
of this as kind of a rough year and it's
coming to a close
uh we should recall that the world is in
a better place today
big picture long term than we were 100
years ago
and as we gird ourselves for progress in
a new year
that's a little bit of inspiration for
you it does get better over time